[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 54 of
the wiggly Google cloud platform podcast
I am Francis Campo and I'm here with my
colleague mark modèle hey Mark how are
doing hi I'm doing pretty well how are
you doing friends ask pretty good pretty
good a very busy day with lots of
podcasting actually today but very
excited about having actually someone
completely new he's a noogler I'm gonna
say yeah yeah he's been working at
Google for two weeks but actually my
monthly like two days yeah and he just
joined after google acquired um apogee a
PG that's it that's a name a toy i
forgot the name yeah yeah so we're going
to be talking about what is what is an
API and what is the API life cycle and
it's a very interesting conversation
he's been doing this for quite a while
so he has a lot of insights on yeah what
you should be looking at when you expose
your FBI takes more than you might think
oh yeah there's a lot of things yeah
yeah it is not just like oh you should
just you should use HTTPS which you
should yeah it's way more than that so
very interesting conversation yeah and
after that we have a lovely extension
from the conversation we had with agile
last week talking a little bit more
about Ruby talking about how you can
interact we'd say Google cloud services
but with an API and a set of libraries
that allowable you to not have vendor
lock-in so you could like move it to
another cloud provider if you so desired
yeah very very interesting actually
makes me wish we had something like that
for go yeah I wonder eight threes we
should check it out we should but before
we get into all of those topics we have
a cool thing of the week which is
brought by yourself mark it it s / by me
um yeah yes I brought it by reading
blogs hey good job it's that kind of day
so recently on the crib annuities blog
there is a really cool tool called
compose that was a great alliteration
composed with AK so if anyone who has
worked with docker before quite often
people they start working with darker
and that's cool that's great and then
they often quoted aku compose when they
have multiple containers they want to
work with and have them work together
and a question I see quite often the
community is oh I've got this compose
thing
a bit then I want to go to Cuba Nidhi's
and I know about composed by don't know
about communities what do i do I don't
know and so this is actually an open
source tool that lets you take Dooku
compose as well as a ducker dab file or
a ducker distributed application bundle
and then you can convert it into
communities deployments and services
using this command line tool either to
push it directly up to Kobernus muffler
yeah or actually just create the files
themselves and then you can edit them as
you see fit cool that is bran so
basically it is like a 1-1 of thing like
you have a big compose file that you've
spent a lot of time building and rather
than having to the manor we just use
that and boom them yeah then you oh I
think it's a really nice little weight
of learning about like containers and
sort of extending it them further into
into different things and then also like
if you're doing a compare and contrast
against swarm versus like communities
damn easy way to bounce between the both
as well that is very cool cool so I
think it's time to go talk with our new
co-worker on a hell let's go do that so
I'm very happy to welcome Alan ho to the
podcast hi Alan how are you doing doing
well so very excited because you're
actually the first person the way
interview that comes from a PG you were
a lead developer for advocacy for RPG
that's right yeah could you tell us a
little bit more about what you do so
kind of my my main job is to help our
customers essentially build better api's
so I do a lot of I work with developers
also work with not just developers but
also architects to build their API
programs and help build better api's
give them consume tips and consulting
help them with the product and I give a
lot of feedback to our own product team
about the usage of a pudgy and I believe
this is your second day Google is that
right uh well technically this is my
second week at Google so we on-boarded
last Wednesday but I was out data API
conference last week right after we on
boarded in
Chicago so second day in the Venice
office nice being Venice the one in Los
Angeles not Venice Italy and now the one
in Los Angeles you're right it's less
fancy super cool though nice so we've
said the word API well the words the the
letters API many many times already why
don't you give us your definition of
what an API is yeah well you know an API
is an application programming interface
but you know today I mean there's a lot
of application have an API is forever
but today when we say api's we we
usually specifically refer to web api's
web api is hosted in the cloud or within
your own data center and so you know i
think there's there's nothing there you
know api's probably the better question
asked is like not what is an API but
rather what makes a good API versus a
bad API I then answer that question yeah
with what does make a good API versus
bad AP I'm happy with that yeah I think
I think like the the primary difference
is kind of your mindset and so there's
the mindset for a lot of developers when
they create api's you think about just
exposing their interface their
application through a you know HTTP
interface that's one way to think about
it but good api's think more about the
consumer they think about it as what's
the easiest way that a consumer can
derive value from the application i
built and when i say the easiest way
that means there's a lot of things that
are necessary to happen it's not just
you know throw a throw on a interface
and you know have a PDF to let you code
against it but there's a lot of kind of
like different steps you need to take
for for building an API but you know I
want I want to turn around like how does
a gcp think about api's and what makes a
good api for gcp standpoint that's a
very good question i'd say that you know
it's something that empowers
our customers to do whatever they need
in the easiest and most efficient way I
think that that is maybe a decent
definition I don't know what do you
think I think you gave a very good
answer princess okay that was not even
prepared yes I think that what you're
what you were pointing at is like it is
not just about giving a way to access
our services like because otherwise you
know doing phone calls could be also an
API somehow that's right it is really as
making it as efficient as possible I
think they should bring back fax
machines I think that's oh yeah that's
what I'm waiting for a thor- that's what
that's how I'm gonna build my API
interfaces from now on so so now that we
have a kind of a good definition an idea
what a good API is uh let's talk about
why why would a company create an API
yeah you know there's there's actually
you know multiple there's multi would
say stages of value that a company can
create an API I mean the first the first
reason is you know a lot of companies
are now building their software actually
has microservices right and all
microservices communicate via API so
anybody any company that's building a
micro service today is essentially
building an API and that's kind of like
the lowest level of value in my opinion
because it just it's all about making
sure that you create these you know you
know connected applications and let
teams not have to work on one big
monolithic application so maybe that's
the lowest level the second level of
companies who are making API is that
they want to expose their their software
as a product right so you know so
basically you know especially if you
want to create a developer if you want
to create a if you if you have a core
value proposition and you need to enable
developers to build on top of it they
exposed to the product I mean the
classic example is mobile apps right
today if you have a mobile app it talks
through an API it's not hitting it's not
hitting
it's not it's not it's usually not a
webpage and even if it is a webpage is
usually a single page app so they're
calling api's so really you need you
need API so that you could have
potentially a variety of clients or
front ends to be able to access the
information that your business or your
service kind of provides without cracker
yeah that's a very it sounds sounds
simplistic but that that is the case and
I think that the highest form of the
api's though is more building an
ecosystem for example walgreens you know
a lot of people know walgreens is a
place where they can pick up drugs or
print out pictures so what they found is
that when people go pick up a picture
they end up doing other things like they
buy you know they buy some chips or they
you know they might buy a toy or do some
grocery shopping things of that sort in
fact they found people who does
something on the web and mobile and then
come into the store or do something have
almost a 6x increase in the amount of
revenue that they spend per store visit
so it becomes an advantage to have as
many you know as much usage of mobile
prior to going into the store so what
they did is that they open up their API
to all these photo apps you know there's
tons of photo apps out there and what
they let you do is they allow people to
print their photos straight from these
photo apps in the store and pick it up
in the store so that way they drive a
lot of foot traffic and they have an
ecosystem of applications that are
driving this foot traffic into the store
so there's multiple you know kind of
levels of reasons and business reasons
why you can use api's and just it just
all matters on which particular use case
and what drives the most business value
cool so as soon as you start doing
things like this though where you're
exposing your api to the world there's a
bunch of things that you're going to
need to start handling like security but
also like quotas and I mean someone is
going to need to pay for those pictures
can you manage how do you manage some
things
well so you know you know as we talked
about like application development life
cycles right there in a similar way
there's what we call the api lifecycle
and I'll kinda I'll step through kind of
the its and it's a fairly it's there are
probably eight make major steps of doing
development and feel free if you've got
questions feel free to interrupt me and
those steps kind of breaking down to
design develop securing your API
publishing your API scaling it
monitoring it analyzing the people who
use the API and last but not least
monetizing your API and so you know for
each of these steps there's you know
there's there's going to be a set of
other task to do so for example when
you're creating your API sorry on your
first designing your API what we
recommend is that you start sharing the
design of your API with your consumers
as quickly as possible you know one of
the one of the very popular standard is
a swagger which has now been rebranded
to open API you know that's a very very
easy way in a language agnostic way to
actually understand whether people like
your API in the first place so getting
customers to actually you know circuit
having the design making sure you have
the tools to circulate that & Co edit
those api's almost like you're editing a
google doc it is going to be a very very
important for making sure your API is
consumable the next step of that is that
when you're developing your api's i'm
not talking about developing the
application logic but your actual AP is
there's a lot of things you also need to
do to so for example if your back-end so
happens to be a you know an old school
soap service you know you may want to
create an API with you know out of the
box that you use some way to convert
like soap to rest right
and especially if you more complicated
use cases you might actually have to
like use JavaScript or node or something
of that sort to you know to facade your
existing back-end then the next step of
that would be to secure your API so
we're talking about like having oooff
you know ssl putting in some what i call
you know threat protection for like
detecting you know sequel injection
script acts things of that sort and one
of the things that people don't realize
with AP is is that unlike web pages you
can leak a lot more data through an API
than a web page the other issue about
and a lot of times when people develop
their API is they try to develop their
api's for as many consumers as possible
so the they end up like returning lots
and lots of information through the API
which is like it's a very very bad
practice so you know making sure your
API is stripping out things that are
sensitive things that the customer
really doesn't need becomes a very
important in security and last but not
least like today you know we've have we
got a lot of denial of service BOTS out
there or bots that scrape websites you
know bots are now getting smart to the
point that they can scrape the api's
themselves so being able to detect a
what we call low and slow attacks and
then doing things like honey pots so
that you can direct you know people to a
fake API you know a mock API instead of
your real data becomes really important
for a security standpoint so it sounds
like there's a bit of a balancing act
there too because obviously if you've
got say an ecosystem that you're
building and you want people to come and
use your API is you kind of want to
expose as much as possible but on the
flip side you don't want to expose
anything that may be sensitive or
harmful how do you kind of combat that
or at least find that that right level
of the sweet spot of where that could be
so that's where it's kind of like what I
would actually do is I would look at the
particular
use case so you might have an API that
might have might be used in a b2b
scenario right once or like a server
calling that API or it might be used
directly by a mobile app in those
scenarios what I would personally
recommend is that you split out you
split them into two different api's
right but one for the mobile app might
have less you know less information and
it would be definitely protected by o
auth and then the one that's meant to be
called from a server it might include it
might have a different authentication
authorization mechanism and serve more
data through it so my kind of
recommendation is that if you have like
multiple use cases that are very very
different that serves different
information don't try to jam it all into
one API but rather have multiple api's
now remember just because you have
multiple api's doesn't mean that you
can't still have one implementation it
just means creating multiple facades on
the same back-end system cool cool
there's a question that I've got a
couple times in since you're here I
wonder if you could answer it which is
let's imagine that you want to have your
API available to the world and you have
an interested on as many people as
possible using it but you have two terms
of service how do you make sure that
only the people that have agreed to
terms of services are things like that
people that are not doing something that
you can see there as abuse of your API
have access to it what we have the kind
of techniques that you would recommend
for that so I mean the if you go to most
cloud providers you know they they have
they basically have different quota
limits for each each user right so first
thing you want to do like if you want
exposes the world like number one thing
to do is create a portal a developer
portal where people can in a
self-service way you know get api keys
and when they sign up for these api keys
you can assign different quota limits
for each of the foot depending on what
their what service they're signing up
for and then in within the gate within
a gateway this is kind of a this is a
purpose of why you would want to have a
gateway in front in front of your AP is
the gateway would be able to do counting
and making sure that people don't exceed
their particular limits cool so I think
I interrupted you in the middle of the
APA lifecycle so we're talking about how
to secure an API what would be the next
step so yeah so after you secure your
API you would publish it so that the
world can see it and in publishing an
API a lot of times like people say oh I
just need to publish the API and
developer portal if I have a public API
well the truth is even if your API is
only being used within your own company
it's probably a good idea to publish it
so that people within your own company
are not kind of reinventing the wheel
it's also really important to have some
sort of you know issue developer keys
even within the within your own org so
that you know you know who within the
company is using your api's and allows
you to communicate to those people when
the api's are going to change or
deprecated and last but not least you
need that for chargebacks as well yeah
so that sounds interesting as well does
the you know I don't know a huge amount
of swagger about open API but does
that's what I help with that process of
being able to communicate about what's
published and what not published and how
those things work yeah so swagger is the
great thing about swagger is that after
you define your model and you define
your api's you can actually annotate
your swagger document and put the
documentation within swagger itself and
what it will do is that you know you can
use a swagger editors to generate the
documentation like live live interactive
documentation cool so instead of just
having like a PDF file you know you can
actually create you can create a live
you know testable you I that you can
actually you know essentially kind of
like do curl commands and it would give
you the actual results so after
publishing then the next thing you need
to do is scale your API and what there's
you know
there's multiples that you know from a
scalability standpoint if your API is
being called from many many clients
around the world you need to make sure
that that you have almost like a CDN you
have points of presence in many many
different data centers all around the
world especially as close as possible to
the consuming client so you know we have
a pudgy has many many data depending on
what kind of service use the on prem
version or the cloud version you know
we're geo distributed and lots of data
centers and we're going to also be
moving on you know not just the an or
main one that we uses amazon web
services but in the future we'll go
obviously going to be doing google cloud
and other cloud platform providers out
there too the other thing too is that
you know from a scaling standpoint it's
also really important to remember that
you can put things like cashing in your
gateway which we reduce a lot of the API
calls your very back-end systems and
that could drastically reduce the cost
that you need to scale your system makes
sense and then after you've kind of
scaled the system the next thing is you
got to make sure the thing doesn't fall
over so having all the dashboards you
know application performance monitoring
dashboards and logging dashboards
becomes really important and one of the
things I tell people is that like yes
you might have logging and application
performance monitoring on your app but
if you have monitoring and logging at
the application interface at the API
layer it actually gives you a much
better sense of what the customer is
actually experiencing so having kind of
like you know monitoring at that layer
not at the application layer but but the
programming interface layer it helps you
quickly diagnose whether your customers
are having a poor you know poor you know
meeting the rest lays things of that
sort because you know your application
is somewhat act like it doesn't
understand which particular users
are using that API in order to
understand this the level of the the SLA
that they have promised the user whether
the API tier does understand that so
that's where becomes very valuable and
two more steps just two more yeah after
you make sure that you're at your thing
is your ear API is stable and it's
meeting it says slays then you got to
figure out who's who's actually using
your API so you know when you're
creating these api's you want to fig
it's almost like a funnel you know it
developers you know a lot of times
developers would you know law you know
sign up for the API and then maybe yeah
thirty or forty percent of them might
actually send an API call and then of
that another maybe ten percent might
actually use your API on a regular basis
and just understanding the those steps
become very important because you know
as developers are using your phone down
this what I called the developer funnel
you may want to engage them in a
different way so for the people who have
used your API there's actually kind of a
magic a top point we found that
developers user api's for three weeks
and maybe not sending traffic every day
but they've been the user track your API
for three weeks you see that the
engagement of that user and the
propensity for them to buy the product
is way way higher so kind of
understanding who's using your api's and
targeting them in a right way becomes
really important just a quick question
now when you say who's using those api's
do you mean specifically like which
applications are using those api's or
actually like which possible customers
through those applications or using
those api's both both yeah so you know
you may want to see you know our is
applications using me more Android
applications using me more you know
those you might want to you know segment
your applications by you know the type
of app but then you might want to
support you might want to like slice and
dice between the types of companies that
are using it so is it a you know startup
developer right or is it a large
enterprise
alright like a large enterprise are very
likely to pay you a lot more money but
if it's a start-up developer for a heart
startup you still may want to engage
them because they could provide you a
lot of great free press for your for
your api's so you understand who is
using your API is becomes critically
important for learning how to engage
those customers cool cool so I think
that you mentioned there was a one last
yeah one last one is you got to make
money ok right profit exactly you know
so being able to you no charge people's
credit cards for you know the simple way
of thinking about monetization is like
the Amazon Web Services way you charge
per API call but the reality is you know
and talk about these api ecosystems for
example walgreens they don't charge for
their api at all right because they they
they are in current they want people to
use their api so that you know more
people come into the store and spend
more money so instead they might have
like internal chargeback mechanisms to
charge other business divisions whenever
they're api's are being used there's
there's multiple like when you think
about monetization you know you need to
think about you know directly monetizing
it indirectly monetizing it or kind of
like internal chargebacks within your
organization cool so that yeah that's
that's the life cycle so that seems like
there's a lot of things that you should
take into account whenever you going to
publish an API which I guess why that
that's the reason why i PG exists at all
yeah so I was wondering if you could
give us a like pre high view of how does
it blow to go through this API life
cycle using a PG yeah so you know we
have a pudgy has as an API management
platform that I mean our goal is to make
it there make it very fast for you to
kind of get through this life cycle
because I just didn't I just rattle off
a ton of ton of steps but
the way the way that we do it is that
you know we provide design tools so we
have a swagger editor I know a swagger /
open API editor that we've contributed
from open source standpoint but we also
have it built into our product so we
encourage people to create their API
design then load their api's then proxy
their API is through a pg's gateway and
that you know provides you the ability
to add security monitoring analysis on
top of it and then we allow people to
publish developer portals in a turnkey
fashion so that you don't have to you
know mess around with Drupal or your own
CMS system and then you know we have
out-of-box connectors for monetization
so whether it's some like you know
payment providers things of that sort we
make it just we just accelerate it and
we provide all the connectors for you to
make it stand up your API program as
quickly as possible awesome I think
we'll definitely get you back to do a
more in-depth analysis of exactly what
effigy can do in the API space but since
we're running out of time some final
questions I wanted to ask what's the
coolest or your favorite was the like
most interesting API you've come across
in all your time working with api's oh
it's the coolest API um I would say very
recently the uber api's are the most
interesting the uber API like uber
provides api's so that you know you can
call a cab from anywhere right and this
allows you to they actually do multiple
things they allow you to like call they
have an API to pick up anybody or
anything and deliver it to somewhere
else right and that that drastically
changes how local commerce is done
because you know when you create a store
and things of that sort there's
automatic assumption of how health you
create stores based on how far you know
it takes to drive there or the reach of
the store and suddenly when you have a
yeah that lets you deliver almost
anything anywhere within a high within a
city in less than 30 minutes you
drastically increase the you know your
you drastically change how stores should
be thought about and how you how you can
connect with customers they also have
cool api's to that even if you're in an
uber and going to the store you know you
can monitor what every single person is
doing and then you know assuming you got
you the user gives from mission and you
don't even let them know about products
that you're about to see or you go
before you get into the store itself so
they've kind of like created this
end-to-end trip experience which is
really going to change how people build
apps as well as how people actually
helps potentially how cities can be
arranged for you know shopping as well
as living so I think that is the
probably the most game-changing API that
I've kind of work with so far ooh and
you know you can go on an apogee blog to
way I had a webcast with their chris
messina the guy who used to work at
Google and invented the cash tag and he
goes through all of those cool use cases
cool we'll have linked to that the show
notes as as usual awesome all right
before we finish up is there anything
interesting or anything we haven't
managed to cover that you want to talk
about before we wrap things up here make
api's great again that's Tok nope that
builds great api's if you have any
questions you can I'm always available
via Twitter and you can also will also
have some show notes and you know get
ahold of me Thank You cool well have a
link to to your Twitter from the show
notes if anyone wants to contact you
right thank you so much take care thanks
thanks again to Alan for joining us
today very interesting conversation more
at a higher level about api's but I
think that's really really good and
really interesting just a lot of things
to sort of consider and talk about when
building up their eyes for services and
people to use yeah I think that this
there's going to be a good reference
episode that we might be able to
used as a table of contents of yep
topics to cover in more depth because
every single one of those steps he
mentioned the API life cycle I think
deserve an episode yeah great so let's
go with a question of the week and the
question of the way today comes from not
from Asia but if the answer comes from
atcha yeah and the question is okay so
let's imagine that I'm building this
application and I want to use some cloud
provider so let's say that i'm currently
using storage so s 3 on amazon and and
i'm considering moving to Google Cloud
Storage at some point is there any way
that I can run my code against an API or
a library that will abstract the detail
of what is the cloud provider so then my
question would be easier yeah so I think
this is really cool so actually Asia who
was on the episode last week does a
cloud minute video on covering exactly
this with storage specifically but
there's a great Ruby library called fog
that literally does exactly what you're
talking about it acts as an abstraction
to a variety a quite a wide variety of
cloud providers through computer dns
storage and several other services that
are commonly available across cloud
providers and what makes this really
really powerful is yeah i could be
running on to AWS interacting with it s3
I work against the API and then if I
want to be like oh let's see how this
works on Google Cloud Storage maybe it's
better maybe it's worse let's find out
all I didn't do is basically change my
provider with dislike my olcak any
authentication details credentials etc
and then I'm good to go I don't have to
change my code I can just push up you
know stuff up in a Google Cloud storage
or whatever it is I'm working with and
then I you know can keep on moving on
from there it is very cool I was taking
now the list of providers they have and
it is like it is more than the all the
cloud providers I know it's crazy it was
like 30 of them it is pretty amazing so
whatever it is that you might be
considering using I think it's a good
idea if you're writing Ruby to go check
it out and have an idea what kind of API
is you could use across any provider
yeah cool so Francis thanks again for
hanging out with me I you
doing anything special I know we have
our team offsite coming up yeah so
currently if everything went fine by the
time this episode is out i'm currently
hanging out in shanghai nice yep so
pretty excited about that holidays
basically and after that back to the
United States to have an offset with the
whole team uh in Los Angeles excellent
so I guess I'll see you there yeah yeah
I will be there that's where I will be
next week or week after that i should
say as well i'm just going to be kind of
hanging out around san francisco things
are winding down for the rest of the
year so cool and then get ready for next
year where I'm actually just give a
little a very short list of things that
places are going to be i will be at
golab io in Florence then I'll go to
foss them in Brussels then I go to go
freaking India and I think that that's
it for now that's up to februari so yeah
that's that's pretty good all I'm really
concerned about is like next and GDC oh
yes that's in February yeah okay that's
gonna be fun so yeah busy busy year next
year but for now foot Vizier pretty calm
yeah very excited about not doing much
excellent well like I said before thank
you so much for joining me for yet
another week have a wonderful trip and
we'll see you all next week thank you
and yea see you all
you
[Music]